so we've been generally talking about
the up uptick and anti-semitic hate
incidents since the election of Donald
Trump is president-elect of the United
States the anti-defamation league Center
on extremism has been monitoring the
reports very very closely and they have
found a huge surge in the proliferation
of racist and anti-semitic graffiti and
vandalism this includes the use of
swastikas and other Nazi imagery there's
been a sharp spike in the reports of
these incidents as well as other
incidents related to identity hate which
we will talk about just a few examples
to to get us sort of started in Crown
Heights in Brooklyn near my old
neighborhood in Brooklyn a swastika was
spray-painted on the sidewalk hit
traditionally Jewish neighborhood a
church in Brown County Indiana was
vandalized with a swastika and it said
Heil Silver Spring Church Trump as well
as homophobic slurs there was a swastika
and the words sig Heil 2016
spray-painted very early or late I guess
the weight depending on how you sort of
characterize it on election night at a
storefront in South Philadelphia and
nearby there was an SUV spray-painted
with the words Trump rules and Trump
black [ __ ] and I had two stories from
being home in Western Massachusetts over
the weekend where there was a sort of
rock face on a hiking trail in East
Hampton Massachusetts that was covered
in anti-semitic pro-trump graffiti as
well as a swastika carved into the
sidewalk near a synagogue in Greenfield
Massachusetts the stories go on and on
and on Rachel and the numbers don't lie
on this there is an emboldened
I dia I don't think more people believe
this stuff right now then two weeks ago
but more people are emboldened in making
these beliefs public that's what I think
has changed there's been not so subtle
anti-semitism all throughout Trump's
campaign I don't know if we're just
forgetting that he's retweeted neo-nazis
you had that image of Hillary Clinton
with cash and a Jewish star which he
later changed to a circle right and then
he had that closing image on his TV ad
which had Janet Yellen and George Soros
and Lloyd Blankfein's so I feel like
this has been apparent and now it's kind
of coming to the fore coming forth in a
large ways and the ADL has also been
keeping a close watch more generally pat
on white supremacist and extremist
groups and their reactions to the Trump
victory and they're thrilled I mean
there's an array of white supremacists
including those associated with the
alt-right that are celebrating Andrew
Anglin a known neo-nazi who runs the
daily stormer web site wrote a column
talking about we won and how great it
all is James Edwards is a white
supremacist who runs the political
cesspool it's a radio show based in
Tennessee he wrote I hope president
Trump shows them no mercy don't be
magnanimous crush the defeated
especially those in the media and make
America great again Kevin McDonald a
well-known anti-semite and a retired
professor wrote that Trump's win is
quote a victory of white people over the
oleg ARCIC hostile elites read Jews and
adding Trump's victory as a blow to the
entire Jewish power structure I guess
that's ignoring Trump's own daughter
who's Jewish they don't seem to care
about that or rationalizing the wet
rationalizing it away in any case this
is America now they love Trump's victory
and you have to wonder what these
anti-semites think that a president
Trump is going to do for them right
because of sure sure I mean Steve
bannon's on his advisory team yeah but
President Trump
president-elect Trump has a daughter a
son-in-law and grandchildren who are
Jewish yeah and as we talked about
earlier in the show Rachel mentioning
Jared Kushner president-elect Trump's
son-in-law presumably going to have a
pretty significant role here I suggested
yesterday Rachel and I wonder what you
think about this that the reason that
the white supremacist right likes Trump
is not necessarily because of what they
think Trump will do but because the
entire scene is going to maybe make
those who fear the rise of white
supremacy lash out in some way which
will then justify violence against them
I mean I'm sort of reaching here but I'm
trying to figure out what it is that
they love because yeah the you know the
Mexican walls probably never gonna
happen the Muslim ban probably isn't
going to happen although
I'm talking about Muslim registration
we'll deal with that tomorrow what is it
that they expect to get from this I'm
not really sure what they expect to get
from this but I hear a lot of people
saying that this is what we are getting
from a type of backlash election very
similar to Nixon's in 1968 and that our
failure to address the frustrations of
the working white middle class is
resulting in this yeah I think that
there's definitely a strong element of
that and there's also a strong element
of this is the first time that white
supremacy played a role during the
campaign and it wasn't immediately
dismissed by Trump he eventually did
disavow David Duke and after saying he
doesn't know who he is even though he
did it cetera et cetera that is
definitely different this campaign and
the ADL is tracking it and we're going
to continue tracking it as well Gamefly
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly.com
slash TDP s